Disney as you know is notorious when it
comes to protecting their world of
characters okay for example if I tried
to use Snow White in a sketch for even
ten seconds the Disney would launch a
lawsuit into my ass
okay that's what they do all right they
have a special missile for that well
yesterday Disney Pixar released a
trailer for their new animated feature I
gotta say the name surprised me a little
bit take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
Cocco name sounds familiar doesn't it
eight years ago Tom Hanks called me Coco
during an interview and it took off it
caught fire check it out Coco
Christopher stop it
Coco Crisp hair O'Brien that catches on
I'll sue you
[Applause]
all right now since we launched the show
on TBS Coco is the name of our shows
website it's the name of our YouTube
channel we sell Team Coco t-shirts it's
also become my nickname it is
international everywhere I travel people
call me Coco my own son calls me Coco
he doesn't know my real name it's how
I'm known in the world for the past
eight years in fact here I am picking up
my dry cleaning or dry cleaning
earlier today check it out hey Mel gaku
actually Coco everyone got cold Coco
names Coco by keiko okay I hope that
wasn't helpful let's get back to the
point the point remains it's my name I
established it it's my brand so Disney I
know you're watching it's time to change
the name of your Coco movie okay yeah
don't you agree
easy to change at this point I'll tell
you what Disney if you don't change it
maybe I'll be forced to make some
changes to my show coming to you from
Warner Brothers Studios in Burbank Conan
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not screwing around
thank you
you